what do we really want to do like what's
the actual impact if at the end of our
Lives we have something that is a
shining Beacon of a different way to do
business that to me is something worth
fighting for
[Music]
what's on deck for today
I am working on the book
[Music]
you know what's going to happen
what they're gonna be like when's the
book coming out yeah whatever you have
to say oh
I don't know what is it are we gonna
mention it just like insert it casually
in this vlog
that's a pretty big deal honestly they
just found out for the first time that's
right I get some messages that are like
offended they're like yo what the [__]
where's the like I need some leads bro
give me real quick this is really the
first time we're kind of seeing you in
the morning and you're not meditating
you're not journaling you're not doing
the red lightsana I mean I should
normally I have like a three hour
routine just so that I'm capable to
function as a human being I have a long
affirmation routine that I do there's a
wall mirror over there that I just
that's where I just say them to myself
you're amazing you're fantastic
people love you
the comments don't mean anything
this is decaf
all decaf yeah
wow
so you drink it just because you like
the flavor uh actually I drink whatever
Layla usually drinks because it's easier
for me to just be like too if someone
gets plastic surgery right of any kind
the real real is that like either say
nothing
or
be positive about it because they can't
change it like you wouldn't say that to
somebody who didn't have their nose
changed but the the feature is still
permanent I had one guy message me and
he started commenting on all my posts
and he was like evil horrible all this
[__] and then I like looked in my inbox
and he was like messaging he was like
you don't want what's best for us
because if you really did you would give
us the name of your plastic surgery he's
like you want us all to be poured ugly
he was like you just don't want us there
were days where like Layla would be not
in as good of a mood and I would try and
be like hey what can I do like let me do
these things and she would still stay in
a kind of a bad mood and so then what
would happen is I would then get Stern
and be like all right do your own thing
and what would happen is that she would
then step out of it
as soon as I got mean
and so then what she taught me is that
if I am mean she will stop being in a
bad mood
right as soon as you have started having
punishment and reward as as things in
your in your dialect and thinking what
happens afterwards kids cry parent gives
them a cookie and you now teach them to
cry to get cookies like it's just like
so simple and the other piece is if you
reward too long afterwards you still
teach them something but not what you
intended a parent for example fast
forward
as a teenager who sneaks out of the
house
right and then they come back
in the middle of the night
and then as soon as they walk in the
door they punish them and so what
happens
you punish a kid for coming home
and then the surprise the kid doesn't
want to come home
what uh what's your day looking like
what's what's on the agenda leadership
meeting
pipeline review
book meeting I have a bi-weekly with two
of our teammates that I try and do with
some of them
non-executive team and you do that every
day you try and block up until like noon
or one or one yeah and then Layla's been
doing such a good job though that there
are more days where I just have nothing
on my calendar at all which is awesome
and amazing why do you like having
nothing on your calendar I just I just
have more time to work
farewell Farewell My Love
sweet queen
little guy for a guy you want a little
you want a little guy
where to start the day you see my little
my little workstation I've got my iPad
which is where I draw my stuff I've got
earplugs I've got my Nicorette my work
timer going so I actually don't use it
all the time it's more during the week
because people ping me I'll just set my
timer for really how long I think
Something's Gonna Take and then I'll hit
it and I just keep it right like in
plain sight and that works really well
so interesting combo is if you go
headphones ear muffs nicotine caffeine
and like work and a timer
I've yet to find like a better
combination of productivity use if
useful
[Music]
[Applause]
acquisition.com
is be able to build acquisition.com to
whatever a billion 10 billion
leading with or he's not punishment if
we could really do this and then teach
other CEOs how to do this if that's
something worthwhile of doing and it's
not like anybody else but on the same
side we have our mission which is to
make real business education available
to everybody
there's often two visions in a company
there's the internal Vision which is
much more relevant to the team and the
employees and the vet vendors and
everyone that you touch and even the
customers and then there's the external
division which is like how are we
affecting the Greater Community that is
affected by acquisition
and I think that we actually really have
to do as we've clarified this
conversation it's been an ongoing
dialogue between Layla and I of like
what do we really want to do like what's
the actual impact at the end of our
Lives we have something that is a
shining Beacon of a different way to do
business that is more profitable by
building something bigger and better but
do it our way which is praise over
punishment that to me is something worth
fighting for it just takes more skill
because when someone messes up all you
want to do is punish them how can I not
do that and then get the desired result
we will Define somebody who is motivated
by reward or reinforcement as someone
who is who utilizes all of their
discretionary effort so if there's the
level of effort that is required to not
get fired and then all the effort above
that is discretionary effort in a
business that is based on punishment
people will go to the law of least
effort which is as little as they can do
to not get fired so if you have a
business that's based on that then how
do you get higher performance well look
at McKinsey look at Goldman Sachs
they'll get a lot of the P industry you
raise the bar
and so what happens is you get really
high performers are the only ones who
can perform in that in that place and
they are driven by anxiety they're
stressed out of their minds they drink
they do drugs they get hooked on porn
whatever it is right to deal with the
stressors in their life but you just
move the bar
and so the alternative is a world where
everybody is working even harder than
that because the law of of least effort
there's still people that are so
talented that they can work medium and
not get fired but you lose out on all of
the discretionary effort that they would
be putting in if they felt that they
were being reinforced in a safe place
and so that's the kind of environment
that we're trying to build I'm not
saying we're perfect we will mess up but
that's that's I think something that's
worth fighting for
so fun story
one of our teammates went to an event
and was rocking in acquisition our
Contra now they're not for sale
obviously and many people came up to him
asking to take pictures with him invited
him out for drinks invited him out for
food to portions of it that he wasn't
allowed to go into but he was able to
because he was wearing that shirt
so how does that happen they read a book
that gives them value they're reinforced
and rewarded for that thing and then
when they do the stuff from the book
they associate the rewards they get from
that with the book the book they
associate with me
and then they see me in all the videos
and all the content with this thing and
So eventually you remove me and you just
keep the thing and you associate that
thing with all these good feelings
all this reward
and so then someone else wears the shirt
and then they feel the same way towards
that person simply because they have
Associated so many good things with that
and that is branding and yes let's
switch to pipeline
that would allow us to do that kind of
vision of the 49 or 51 for new companies
just adding them straight to kind of
like our Top Line bottom line that would
be a huge move
what was that what was that meeting that
we were just in this is our pipeline
review so it's looking at the companies
at different stages in the deal process
and you know mind you of people who even
get to this level 95 percent of deals we
don't do
um it's just because we're looking for a
lot of very specific things it's not
just necessarily like is the company
valuable but like can we add value to
the company fundamentally there's two
schools of investing there's Bettors and
Builders so Bettors are like can I find
a mispriced company that I will simply
put money in at less than its intrinsic
value and then hope that it will grow
over time that's kind of like the Warren
Buffett style probably the vast majority
of investors are that way and then there
are Builders who have like a unique set
of skills in their hold code that they
try and templatize those kind of like
Sops those playbooks and just deploy
them into the companies knowing that
they're going to Triple 5x 10x the
companies that they have private Equity
is usually a combination of both those
things I would say that we lean towards
the building side of like we're not
trying to be like amazing Pickers we
just try and find companies that we know
our playbooks will immediately 10x and
then try and work with them it was
texting
my wife gosh
I'm pumped because in the in the new
place I will be able to fit my entire
wardrobe in my bedside table oh yeah
we'll show Layla's entire closet and
then I will pull out my two drawers with
beaters and shorts
it'll be great why are you so obsessed
about that stuff well I will say this I
don't know why
I know that I am I have become more that
way
because it's probably been reinforced
the more obsessive I am about like
iterating things until they're like just
right
the more rewarded I get Trevor's saying
that like that he's alarmed by the
number of people that he has worked with
who do not read well he said we need to
teach them to read he got a kid who was
struggling to stay focused and so he
came to train the kid with a bag of
Skittles the kid would read three words
and he would give him a Skittle but if
he read four words because if his
previous best was three he would give
him two skills
so we reinforce him doing it every time
he had a bigger reinforcement for when
every time he hit a new record so if he
read a full line
he would give him more by the end of the
first session he had them reading entire
Pages hello
so we're doing this whole Vlog thing so
we're we're capturing Day in the Life
the very you know the high energy life
of the CEO who lives in a closet
you have anything excited yeah I mean
like I don't see an issue with
translating into more languages like
that doesn't bother me then we just have
more people who get the book can they do
mandarin or Japanese or Portuguese
Portuguese would be big German I got a
lot of DMS after I showed the French one
so that was a meeting with my book
manager who also happens to be my
father-in-law so we have massively
improved our relationship since the
first time I stole his daughter told her
to quit everything to join me to
gallivant across the country living in
motels six weeks after we met uh
but yeah he runs everything with the
book so we have a French and a Spanish
version out and then looking at other
languages that we want to translate it
into and looking at publishing and
printing firms in Germany and Italy so
that's kind of what that that meeting
was about we've got uh different
versions of the books as they progressed
over time from different printers so
that I could see the print quality just
so you guys know I don't go to one
printer I go to a bunch of them and make
sure that the book quality is good and
if you're like well why are you even
dealing with this rather than going over
publisher because Publishers don't want
you to give away your book for free
and so I uh you know Uncle Alex foots
the bill I'll have probably a million
I'll add it up probably like a million
two into this book negative I mean
that's why most publishing companies
will front the money and I would have
done that with this book just so you
guys know except if I had done it with
this book it wouldn't be out until uh
spring of 24. like it has to be 100 done
nine months before you actually get it I
finished this and then I'm releasing it
16 weeks after it was done and that's
because 12 weeks is printing if I wanted
to just do like Dropship real-time
Printing and then wanted everyone to
wait forever I would do it that way but
it's also way more expensive to print
that way and uh you know the books fund
Mosey media
which is really so you guys know where
did the dollars go from the from my 2.99
books that I get a dollar from it goes
to go to the team so we can put out more
stuff for you guys Tobias what's up man
tell me your most painful moment
it's tough I mean like cutting my
eyeball that sucks I took sales call
still so yeah there you go
yeah okay
um I would just get your opinion on
fixing the sales issue here's what's
crazy is that if the other guy gets up
to 40 at Double sales I think that if I
had a two-prong approach get a good
salesman in there and then double the
throughput on the webinar I would say
like that's a 4X if we double double
sometimes people ask why don't you make
videos like you used to why why the
change why all the editing the new
thumbnails all that [__]
more people see it
I mean it's just that we see the
comments this actually reminds me of a
story that you told me but like whenever
a band goes from like a small town to
like they go they go bigger audience
they go more mass Market people are like
the band's selling out or whatever it is
but the reality is that like the band
morphs into the thing that reaches the
most people and so if you believe in the
message that you have then packaging it
in a way that allows the most people to
consume it
if you believe in what you want to get
out there as long as it doesn't dilute
the core message which I don't think us
editing more heavily and having higher
produced videos does it just gets more
people to see it and so here's the thing
is that everyone in Mosey Nation votes
with their clicks and their eyeballs
about the things they find most
interesting and so you train me
to make the content that I have
so if y'all in general
liked the webcam only thing more than I
would be making more of that
you train me with your clicks and your
watches of the things that you care the
most about and so we make more of those
things so in many ways you guys control
the content and to all the day one
homies
appreciate y'all many of you guys were
like at 5K we're like dude this guy's
gonna be in a Million
and it's true I got there but it was
just because you guys appreciate you
guys sharing commenting send it to your
friends all that kind of stuff I feel
really confident in saying that like
in two years you will laugh at what we
are putting out right now
um I know I certainly will there are
some things that are going to get
released that are going to blow what we
are doing out of the water we like to
say we think of decades not days
um but I think you can just
watch and see if if we're full of it or
not